mais d'abord l'actualité donc cette
question comment restaurer la confiance
des français dans leur justice c'est
sans doute le point de départ des états
généraux qui ont été lancés cet après
midi par le président de la république
pour en débattre j'accueille cécile
mamelin bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes vice présidente de l'union
syndicale des magistrats alain richard
bonsoir aussi sénateur du val-d'oise
membres du groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
jean pierre mignard vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris docteur en droit
avec nous également en visioconférence
stanislas go donc et délégué général du
syndicat de police alliance et bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi évidemment
matthieu croissandeau éditorialistes
présent à mes côtés les lundis et
mercredis on attend je pense qu'on
devrait enfin je l'espère récupérer une
déclaration du président république
voilà pour lancer ces états généraux
mais mais d'ores et déjà cécile mam là
qu'est ce que vous en attendez si vous
en attendez quelque chose
écoutez ce qu'on peut déjà dire c'est
que le timing pour nous n'est pas
tellement propice à une réflexion
profonde sur la justice nous sommes en
fin de quinquennat j'ai écouté
attentivement
effectivement le discours je dirais
d'introduction de ces états généraux
j'ai eu plus le sentiment d'assister à
la fois un bilan du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron et peut-être aussi à
la préparation d'un deuxième quinquennat
s'il était réélu donc les idées qu'il a
avancées sont des idées effectivement
comme ce qui caractérise un petit peu
notre président ce sont des idées
parfois très très disruptive puisque
c'est un mot un petit peu à la mode vont
bien sûr chez nous il y avait quand même
des idées qui vont probablement ne pas
entrer dans notre feuille de route on a
le sentiment que c'est une feuille de
route qui est donnée ou aux états
généraux ce qui est un peu gênant
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il a envie que les citoyens ils
participent que ce soit un débat profond
mais à quelques mois d'une
présidentielle
alors qu'on a eu un quinquennat marqué
par de nombreuses réformes de très
nombreuses réformes on est quand même en
pleine discussion à la représentation
nationale sur une loi pour restaurer la
confiance des citoyens dans la justice
mais moi je ne comprends pas
personnellement cette temporalité
richard ça voudra dire quoi qu'on peut
plus réformé six mois
avant une présidentielle on pourrait
rétorquer cet avion j'entends
fréquemment cet argument est évidemment
très noble mais je me dis au fond est ce
qu'il y aurait une bonne date
je rappelle que cette affaire ne vient
pas tout à fait par hasard ni par
fantaisie à l'été a explicitement
demandé par les deux chef suprême de la
magistrature judiciaire
je pense qu'il y avait un peu réfléchi
et connaissant
ça n'est pas venu de nulle part donc il
ya des sujets qui sont permanents et
notamment celui par lequel vous
commenciez c'est à dire le sujet de la
difficile compréhension entre la masse
de notre société
beaucoup de citoyens nous les entendons
un peu tous les jours et l'institution
judiciaire bon c'est désormais un nom
pourquoi pas plutôt
oui en effet mais je vous dis simplement
que d'abord c'est cette formule est
toujours critiquer quand on essaye de la
parle aux gens de faire quelque chose le
participatif parce que ça donne toujours
l'impression enfin en tout cas ce qu'ils
ont ou défavorable cherche toujours à
dire oui mais en réalité ça manipule sas
a cherché à construire autre chose et c
est long je sais pas comment il faudrait
le faire pour éviter les critiques mais
je pense que c'est quand même mieux de
le faire que de ne pas le faire jean
pierre mignard uni 3 c'est bon à prendre
même si c'est un peu tard non mais ce
que
ce que vous disiez madame est juste
c'est à dire que on est à proximité des
shows électorat qui sont très importants
république donc on n'évitera pas en
effet sur deux
d'embouteillage pour éviter le collapse
est tout simplement donc peut-être en
effet que ici ou là on aura tendance à
radicaliser les positions parce qu'on
sera effectivement dans une même période
mais enfin comme restaurer la confiance
j'ai toujours entendu cela ça fait
vraiment de dizaines d'années pardon que
j'entends dire qu'il faut restaurer la
confiance qu'on est dans une ciste aide
les français sont en défiance de vie de
la justice donc c'est constant alors
donc c'est peut-être vrai mais c'est pas
c'est bien c'est vrai il s'est
constamment vrai peut-être d'ailleurs
réfléchir en quoi effectivement c'est
cette autorité ou ce pouvoir
et toujours effectivement c'est ancré de
l'insatisfaction c'est à dire sa
fonction et indépendamment de ça je
pense qu'il serait bon à prendre ce sont
des bas je suis avec vous même faites
pour et prenant la balle au bond et
essayons d'en faire quelque chose c'est
ce que j'ai envie de dire
mathieu il ya quand même une opportunité
politique aussi pour le président
république oui c'est sûr que le
calendrier étonne parce que j'ai une loi
qui en discussion au parlement pour
restaurer la confiance dans la justice
et donc pourquoi on mènerait des états
généraux de la justice juste après alain
richard l'a rappelé c'est vrai que c'est
pas une demande de l'exécutif c'est
l'exécutif qui
acquiesce à cette demande était fait par
les deux plus hautes figures la
magistrature et ça tombe pas par hasard
ça ton quand même dans une année où la
justice a été mise en cause comme
rarement attaqué que ce soit par des
syndicats de policiers que ce soit par
des politiques et donc je pense que
c'est une réponse demandée par
l'institution à cette crise il est plus
forcément une crise de confiance on a
dépassé ça c'est une crise de modèle en
crise une crise politique
moi j'y vois plutôt au delà de cette
bizarrerie et de ce peut-être sept cet
agenda politique n'échappe à personne
parce qu emmanuel macron de la même
façon qu'ils souhaitaient en jambes et
tous les scrutins intermédiaires le
voilà qui essayent d'enjamber la
présidentielle en lançant un chantier
qui démarrerait avant le scrutin et qui
se terminerait ou après entrerait en
application oui et puis se révolter en
tout cas après
on est quand même dans une campagne
présidentielle où la justice devient un
sujet et le thème de surenchère entre
toutes un nombre de candidats et je
trouve que si jamais ces états généraux
sont menées de façon indépendante comme
le présent macron l'a proposé ou en tout
cas l'a promis ensuite il faudra
vérifier qu'il n'y a pas là à la main
noire de l'exécutif derrière qui tente
de peser sur les débats mais si ces
débats sont menés de façon indépendante
si les magistrats disent qu'ils ont sur
le coeur propose des réformes profondes
ça évitera aussi peut-être à des
candidats de dire n'importe quoi et de
proposer des choses qui sont parfois
contraire sinon notre constitution en
tout cas à l'esprit l'esprit de concorde
et de justice qui anime ce pays depuis
depuis longtemps alors oui un aspect
aussi bilan du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron je vous propose d'entendre le
mystique le garde des sceaux qui se
défend des 7 et 8 octobre dernier
notamment sur la hausse du budget
regardez c'est drôle la vie c'est
parfois très injuste
regardez le taux de chômage en ce moment
là jamais aussi bas ça fait parfois une
petite ligne je devrais dire une ligne
est dans les journaux alors que quand le
chômage était très haut sous d'autres
quinquennat on disait mais le président
de la république l'exécutif ne sont pas
parvenus là on y est parvenu et on nous
rend pas justice que ça la croissance
c'est pareil et moi je veux d'abord me
batte me parler de violence moi je veux
d'abord me battre sur mon bilan parce
que j'ai un vrai bilan ici la justice de
proximité c'est quelque chose et c'est
quelque chose que les français touche
dès à présent du doigt dans leur réalité
quotidienne voilà eric dupond moretti
qui était sur elle si j'appelle
alexandre poussard à nos jeunes bonsoir
alexandre de vous accueillir dans ce
sens public pour aller un peu plus loin
là il ya les mots du ministre mais si on
reprend un peu les grandes réformes du
quinquennat maquereau en matière de
justice alors les mots du ministre sur
le budget il faut reconnaître qu
emmanuel macron a considérablement
augmenté le budget de la justice sur le
quinquennat avec une hausse de 2
milliards d'euros cela représente 33%
une hausse de 33 % du budget et puis
l'autre ambition d' emmanuel macron
c'était de lutter contre la
surpopulation carcérale le candidat
macron avait promis la création de 15000
places de prison supplémentaires
et finalement le président macron en
aura fait sortir de terre à la fin du
quinquennat seulement 7000 le reste de
ses places de prison est reportée à 2027
une réforme des peines est également
menée avec la fin des peines inférieures
à un mois de prison est le développement
des alternatives à la prison comme le
bracelet électronique ou encore les
travaux d'intérêt général mais au final
la surpopulation carcérale n'a pas
baissé avec un taux d'occupation des
prisons de 113 % en août 2000 21 c'est à
dire au même niveau que 2000 17 et puis
autre réforme importante du début du
quinquennat la simplification de la
carte judiciaire le tribunal de grande
instance et le tribunal d'instance ont
fusionné pour donner le tribunal
judiciaire ce une simplification et qui
profite aux justiciables tout en
conservant le nombre de tribunaux sur
notre territoire et puis alexandre on
l'a évoqué au début de ce débat il ya
les réformes en cours notamment pour
renforcer la confiance des français mais
oui vous le disiez avec un projet de loi
intitulé projet de loi renforçant la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
c'est un texte qui a déjà été voté en
première lecture au parlement
il supprime les jurés populaires pour
juger certains crimes et délits cela
doit accélérer le traitement de
certaines affaires des procès pourront
être filmé ça va permettre aux citoyens
à d'avoir davantage accès au travail
judiciaire et puis le secret des avocats
de la défense sera davantage protégés et
puis enfin une réforme symbolique
importante dans la fin de ce quinquennat
macron c'est la réforme du régime
d'irresponsabilité pénale qui est porté
par le gouvernement en réaction à la
sphère sarah halimi sara lee mis cette
femme tuée à son domicile et dont le
meurtrier a été déclarée par la justice
irresponsable pénalement alors qu'il
était sous l'emprise de stupéfiants et
cette décision de justice est bien là
beaucoup choqué l'opinion publique et
donc emmanuel macron a décidé de
légiférer sur ce sujet d'ailleurs ce
texte est en débat aujourd'hui au sénat
aujourd'hui maseda merci alexandre à
tout à l'heure dans notre sol en débat
évidemment jean pierre mignard vous
disiez attention
à la multiplication des textes c'est
vrai que vous craignez ça c'est une
sorte de calendrier ultra serré enfin
non plus des lois comme des lapins c'est
à dire qu'il ya un problème la loi elle
doit infuser d'abord on doit prendre le
temps de la travailler le plan de la
connaître le temps de la disputer le
temps de la discuter après tout c'est le
travail qu'on a constamment les avocats
et les magistrats donc attention c'est
très bien c'est à dire qu'il ya un
travail législatif que les
parlementaires travaillent ça sur ce
point en tout cas ils reprochent le
populiste qui n'est pas acceptable
simplement il faut le temps de la fusion
il fonde le temps de la compréhension et
font le temps de l'intelligibilité là il
ya eu quand même une masse deloitte qui
pour beaucoup ne sont pas effectivement
intégré ni connu pour l'essentiel mais
après tout l'occasion fait le larron le
dossier le fait donc ça sur ce point
c'est une première question deuxième
c'est que cette pilule monde doit à mon
avis ne s'est pas accompagné d'une
réflexion mais ça c'est très
caractéristique du canada des macros on
travaille beaucoup mais quel est le quai
lequel analyse en surplomb ont fait
c'est quoi le rôle de la justice dans
une démocratie comme le nom comme la
nôtre maintenant il ya des piliers ya
l'exécutif il ya législatif c'est quoi
le pilier judiciaire quelle place
occupe-t-il dans la société
quelle place deux dans ces conditions
les magistrats doivent t'ils occupée
quelles fonctions et quelles protections
doit-elle leur être donnée je pense
notamment aux magistrats du parquet
voilà je pense qu' il manque une
réflexion de fond parce que la macro il
est pragmatique et pragmatique libéral
et pragmatique mais à un moment donné on
a besoin d'une sorte de doctrine de
corps de références théoriques vous
faisions une certaine façon à une vision
c'est peut-être un peu beaucoup ne sont
pas des prophètes mais peut-être devient
voilà dans quel cadre de société quel
équilibre entre les pouvoirs et qu'elle
pilier effectivement chacun doit
s'efforcer de construire un à richard ce
que ça a manqué finalement fusionné dans
le bilan du quinquennat macron intervenu
je ne peux que sympathisé avec la
description que fait jean pierre
c'est vrai que enfin à mon avis j'ai
définir la vision ou en tout cas
l'architecturé globale tiens qui inspire
le président c'est simplement le respect
du principe
de l'état de droit et la tradition
judiciaire je ne crois pas qu'il ait
pour l'avoir entendu à quelques moments
discuter de ces sujets là je crois pas
qu'il ait une volonté
de transformation complète du système
quand il dit leur volonté de rendre
plus efficace jeu je suis quelqu'un de
d'impoli j'emploie fréquemment le terme
de management judiciaire parce que les
moyens de la justice est un gros mot
pour savourer je suis bien j'ai bien dit
non mais il m'arrive d'être un contenant
jeu je pense que la justice demande à
être être utilisés efficacement dans le
sens du service public on va y venir à
l'efficacité mais quand même sur le
positionnement des macros et sur la
séparation des pouvoirs et et sa vision
de la justice ces propos sont des propos
rapportés du présent la république juste
avant la mise en examen du garde des
sceaux il est en conseil des ministres
voilà ce qu'il dit la justice est une
autorité par un pouvoir je ne serai pas
la justice devenir un pouvoir d'abord
c'est la constitution donc ce n'est pas
très original
deuxièmement les récollets racontars de
sortie du conseil des ministres sont
tous là qu'on n'a pas été démentie avec
des pincettes malheureusement si en plus
on se mettait à développer un dialogue
sur des sur un manquement ne vous dis
que ça reflète pas forcément sa pensée
nous en tout cas rires il il a dû être
comment dire
ennuyé par telle ou telle décision
d'ailleurs je n'entends le magistrat
sein de la juridiction administrative
que de les juridictions judiciaires
donc il est possible que ça joue aki qui
est il arrivé de ne pas la voir à un
moment d'humeur mais je ne crois pas du
tout qui un sujet de prise de pouvoir
par là par l'autorité judiciaire les
règles constituent elles sont claires et
personne ne songe à l'est à les faire
évoluer cécile mam la danseuse dans ce
bilan du quinquennat 2 du présent et
public il ya évidemment le la nomination
puis la situation judiciaire il faut
bien l'aborder de du garde des sceaux
d'eric dupond-moretti mais moi ce n'est
pas tellement de salon j'ai envie de
vous parler j'ai envie de réagir aux
propos effectivement de monsieur richard
c'est que ce qu'on regrette beaucoup au
niveau des magistrats c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas une prise effectivement claire
de position de notre président un public
qui est garant de l'indépendance de la
justice au moment des affaires vous avez
évoqué effectivement qu'elles ont
déclenché cette demande des deux plus
hauts magistrats de france si on en est
arrivé à demander des états généraux
éventuellement de la justice c'est parce
que le président de la république au
moment de ces manifestations de
policiers qui ont été d'une violence
inouïe n'ont fait l'objet d'aucun je
dire donc un rappel à l'ordre d'aucuns
rappellent aux principes par notre
président de la république qui est le
garant de l'indépendance et du respect
dû à l'institution judiciaire on en est
arrivé là à cause de cela il a fallu
attendre aujourd'hui ce discours
d'intronisation aux états généraux de la
justice pour avoir un début de
reconnaissance du travail de des
magistrats et encore je l'aï entendu
très peu il a parlé des fonctionnaires
il a parlé des avocats qui sont le
maillon essentiel n'a malheureusement
pas beaucoup parlé des magistrats donc
ce qui est dommage c'est qu'on ait
attendu aussi longtemps et en fin de
mandat et je envie de vous dire aussi
qu'il y a quand même eu deux promesses
de fait dans le cadre aux vingt deux
idées qu'il a émis dans le cadre de ce
discours qui sont des idées qu'il avait
déjà émis dans le cadre de sa première
campagne à savoir la suppression de la
cour de justice de la république et le
changement effectivement processus de
nomination des parcs et on en est encore
là alors ne me dit pas il ya eu la crise
qu vie il ya eu des choses ça n'était
pas si compliqué ça c'est une réforme
qui n'aurait pas dû coûter tant d'argent
que cela est ce que j'ai envie de dire
aussi c'est que la succession de
réformes comme l'a évoqué m e mignard
tout simplement insupportable à digérer
pour la magistrature qui est dans un
état de réel manque de moyens qui
perdure malgré l'augmentation du budget
que nous donnions pas mais ramener ça
aux standards européens nous sommes très
loin du compte nous avons fait les
calculs il nous faudra plusieurs
décennies à ce rythme on embauche de
magistrats parce que sous le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro on est passé en 2010
est de 148 création d'emplois de
magistrats à cette année pour la
deuxième fois que 50 et 47 greffiers
donc c'est ça aussi la réalité et pour
les services judiciaires qui sont les
tribunaux c'est à dire ceux qui
travaillent pas l'administration fait
dire ce qui qui exercent ont juridiction
qui rendent les décisions et bien là
c'est que 14 % d'augmentation et quand
on sait qu'on consacre moitié moins
d'argent par habitant pour le budget de
la justice par rapport à l'allemagne
alors que l'allemagne sont plus nombreux
et qu'ils ont ou si une équipe autour du
magistrat on nous parle beaucoup de
l'équipe autour du magistrat on est tout
à fait d'accord pour réfléchir à la
façon de mieux travailler mais pour
moderniser une institution il faut lui
donner les moyens emmanuel macron s'est
dit on peut s'inspirer des pays
européens mais oui inspirons-nous des
pays européens mais aussi sur les moyens
alors je vais rebondir ce que menait le
nombre de juges pour 100000 habitants
effectivement on est loin de de
l'allemagne c'est plus de 24 24 enfin
c'est une moyenne dans en allemagne
présence des jurés en belgique 11 en
italie à peine 11 en france juste une
chose que les systèmes sont vraiment
comparable parce qu'il entre l'allemagne
la france toute une partie de des juges
qui sont je crois aux prud'hommes qui
sont exercées non pas par des juges mais
par où des tribunaux de commerce qui
sont pas exercées par des jumeaux mais
ça c'est le magistrat professionnel mais
par de huit professionnels et même
d'allemagne français sondés jugent les
n'est
pas ce que je sais le groupe sont sont
répertoriés par rapport aux pays bas
évidemment
notamment le portugal et ses projets
nous la belgique ils ont plus de juge
ils sont beaucoup plus au procureur et
je rappelle que procure en français est
quand même celui qui a le plus de
missions à accomplir savez vous combien
par exemple un procureur pour lutter
contre les violences intrafamiliales qui
a été le sujet de l'année de 8 21
combien de circulaires lorsque j'ai
entendu discours un emmanuel macron qui
nous dit il ya eu moins circulaire cette
année permettez moi de dire que ce n'est
pas tout à fait la vérité il y a eu 10
circulaire de politique pénale en
matière de violence sont un familial
cela il faut le gérer pour l'appliquer
en juridiction tout cela il faut y
consacrer du temps des moyens et quand
on parle d'humanité les citoyens parler
beaucoup d'humanité les juges de la de
façon très majoritaire sont des gens
humains mais on ne les traite pas
forcément en toute humanité pour qu'ils
puissent exercer leur métier alors est
ce qu on sait ce que la priorité c'est
nommé plus de juges renforcer le nombre
de simplement les moyens des juges jean
pierre mignard et ensuite un oui il
faudra faire bien sûr qu'il faut
renforcer les moyens des juges ça c'est
une certitude et puis d'ailleurs
permettent sur ce point le dialogue le
plus intense avec les avocats mais je
viens tout de suite au procureur je vois
que revient dans le débat et c'est
normal sur une vieille question le
monstre du loch ness attend passer d'un
système inquisitoire où c'est
effectivement
le juge qu' à la fin quand même procès
décision mais où un système accusatoire
ou dans ces conditions le procureur
reprendrait progressivement la
succession du juge d'instruction celui
ci pouvant être d'ailleurs voué à sa
disparition ça a été évoqué par ça a été
évoqué donc c'est une question était
quand même très très fréquemment reprise
sous le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
l'actuelle garde des sceaux est proche
de la pensée de l'ancien président de la
république donc il est possible qu'on y
vienne ce qui va poser immédiatement la
question du statut des procureurs je ne
sais pas ce n'est plus seulement
maintenant la question de savoir
si ils reçoivent des instructions aussi
et c'est madame taubira sur ce point a
fait une loi qui dorénavant interdit de
donner des instructions dans les
dossiers même si il y à une
communication par le haut qui doit
revenir avec des critères qui sont plus
ou moins compliquées mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui on n'intervient plus il est
des gouvernements qu'ils n'intervenaient
pas ce monsieur justin madame guigou
même avant monsieur magri et des
ministres qui étaient sur ce point
impeccable mais maintenant il va falloir
que la mon sens les procure un soin
comme les magistrats du siège et
protégés comme les magistrats du siège
avec une carrière qui soit exactement
celles des magistrats du siège sous
l'autorité du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et de lui seul donc ont
coûté cher et man le cordon avec bien
sûr alors le code le cordon pas tout à
fait sûr que lorsque
discutant avec un procureur je dois
avoir la même confiance en lui parce que
je discute ou que je discutais avec un
magistrat du siège je ne veux pas être
polémique si je discute avec un
procureur je ne discute pas avec le
ministre ou son représentant ou son
oreille nous sont des murs c'est très
important donc même pour les années car
cette impression de temps en temps ah
oui mais vous savez j'ai une longue
période de connaissance du monde
judiciaire mais je ne dirais pas ça
publiquement parce que nous sommes quand
même des gens du secret pas peut-être
des ponts beau mais je sais trop bien
comment cela fonctionne et ça s'est
beaucoup améliorée je pense pas
d'ailleurs que ce gouvernement soit
particulièrement intrusif même s'il
garde des sceaux n'a pas une grande
amitié on le voit bien pour son
administration judiciaire va face à un
gouvernement qui se proclament libéral
sur le libéralisme politique que je dis
c'est au libéralisme politique pure et
simple les magistrats du parquet doivent
être des magistrats du siège
complètement protégé ce qui permettra
d'élire aux avocats dette en toute
confiance avec eux ce qui serait quand
même un grand progrès alors ils
s'arrêtent pour lui sur nous souhaitons
cette réforme ça fait un moment qu'elle
est en débat la majorité conservatrice
du sénat sion pose avec régularité et
l'efficacité il faut le reconnaître il
faudra reprendre le dossier je pense que
ce serait bien que la plupart des
candidats significatif à l'élection
présidentielle se prononce sur ce sujet
là mais moi je sais de quel côté se
s'exprimera emmanuel macron et j'espère
que la prochaine fois nous irions savoir
en revanche ça va être quelque côté
s'exprimera pas déconner il défendra
l'idée qu'il a défendues en début de
quinquennat c'est à dire il faut que les
procureurs bénéficie d'un système de
domination qui garantit leur
indépendance à ses compositions heureux
qu'elle ne changera pas en revanche et
là je ne sais pas de quel côté penche
jean pierre mignard mais pour ma part je
serais vraiment pas favorable à ce que
nous passions un système accusatoire qui
développe beaucoup l'inégalité entre on
est tout à fait l'éloge et donc
je me sens très bien avec l'adresse
tradition labit napoléonienne du
procureur représentant la société alors
j'aimerais qu'on aborde maintenant la
question de
de la confiance avec les citoyens et
peut-être pour ouvrir ce chapitre un
constat celui d'une d'une étude qui a
été réalisée d'ailleurs pour le sénat
pour l'agora de la justice qui a été
lancé fin septembre au sénat et tu ne
connais pas ses services avec ce chiffre
allait vous confiance dans la justice
non 53% quelques adjectifs quelle image
de la justice l'image la justice lente à
93% opaque à 69% laxiste à 68% éloigné à
67% je reprends le constat qui est
peut-être celui qu'on entend le plus
depuis le plus longtemps et je vais
donner pour la première fois dans ce
débat la parole à un stanislas godeau
qui est qui a délégué général du
syndicat de police alliance sur le
laxisme est ce que vous partagez ce
constat des français qui ont été
interrogés par csa pour l'agora de la
justice au sénat
en fait c'est le constat tout simple que
les policiers font au quotidien parce
que vous savez quand vous interpeller
lorsque vous mettez à disposition la
justice et que vous apercevez que ce
sont les mêmes personnes que vous
retrouvez au même endroit qui parfois
commettre sont en état de récidive
voire de réitération ça dépend des cas
eh bien vous avez en fait une absence de
réponse qui instaure ce que l'on appelle
une impunité et d'ailleurs c'est
impunité elle est tellement installé que
maintenant en fait ces individus
ont décidé en fait 2 2 de se moquer
notamment de l'autorité de l'état des
policiers sur le terrain en arguant
d'ailleurs en nous expliquant que de
toute façon ils risquent rien et qu'on
pourra toujours les interpeller il ne se
passera rien et vous savez quand vous
parlez des sondages il ya un sondage au
dos que ça notamment février 2021 qui
avait été éditée et qui disait que 83%
des français trouvaient que les
condamnations n'était pas suffisamment
sévère alors je parle simplement pour
les délits 88 % estimaient qu'elle était
inefficace insuffisante pour lutter
contre la récidive et que 83% des
français disaient qu'elle n'était pas
bien appliquées parce que c'est un sujet
que l'on porte mon depuis 2002 sur
notamment l'application des peines parce
que si madame expliquaient que les
procureurs avaient de grandes
difficultés parce qu'ils y tension
charge de travail eh ben les policiers
c'est exactement la même chose entre 400
et 500 dossiers qu'ils ont en gestion et
bien vous vous doutez bien que il n'est
pas possible pour eux de mener des
enquêtes correctement là aussi la
question des moyens se pose mais la
question de la politique pénale et l'est
d'autant plus forte que lorsqu'on
regarde un peu les chiffres de près on
nous parle de 83 % de réponses pénales
mais en fait quand on regarde sur les
condamnations en fait on s'aperçoit soit
tout simplement qu'il vient seulement 20
% notamment de condamnation à de la
prison ferme ou avec du sursis partiel
et puis dernier élément les policiers
vous savez on vient enfin d'avoir les
chiffres sur trois années des
condamnations des individus qui
commettent soit des menaces soient des
agressions à l'encontre des policiers et
quand on regarde les quantum moyens qui
sont prononcés eh bien ça nous fait
extrêmement peur et ça illustre notre
propos notre sentiment que pourrait dire
que pourrait décrire certains quand vous
avez par exemple des agressions à
l'encontre des policiers avec des hits
était inférieure à huit jours et qui
sont 1 quand un moyen de 6 mois alors
que la peine encourue est de trois ans
et c'est pour ça que nous avons demandé
à ce qu'ils la création de cet
observatoire de la réponse pénale pour
faire la lumière par territoire sur
comment est-ce que ça se passe lorsqu'il
ya une infraction qui est commise la
peine encourue la peine prononcée et la
peine exécutée et là on saura réellement
de quoi on parle dans ce débat sans
oublier évidemment les victimes parce
que souvent on a tendance à oublier les
victimes dans ce débat important parce
que les victimes vous savez on les
reçoit lorsqu'il dépose plainte et aussi
on les reçoit quand ils nous demandent
des comptes alors je vous donnerai la
parole évidemment il y avait beaucoup
d'éléments et et de prises de position
et d'information peut-être jean pierre
mignard sur le conseil général deux à la
fois du sondage de ce chiffre de 66 pour
2 68% français qui disent la justice
laxiste et c'est ce que relève stanislas
gones ont d'une certaine façon à travers
tous les chiffres qu'il a égrainé là est
ce que c'est un sentiment c'est une
perception c'est une réalité pour un
sentiment c'est une réalité tout son
temps pour l'invs entrer dans cette
discussion interminable que je ne
connais que trop donc c'est une réalité
paradoxalement voyez sa soeur alors à
des chiffres alors peut-être que les
chiffres sont précisément
invincible on ne peut rien faire contre
eux et donc on les écarte quand même les
jouets dans le monde que les peines
avait doublé en faveur 40 ans est
impressionnant des condamnations ont
doublé en 40 ans généralement pour les
mélanges délit oui mais bien sûr donc
vécu et gazier les identités
d'infraction d'élite alors bien sûr la
démographie n'est pas la même et c'est
bien sûr un doublé deuxièmement une
surpopulation carcérale est à côté la
cote est stable donc ça veut dire que on
continue non seulement de condamner mais
on va construire de nouvelles on va
avoir des nouvelles places de prison
vimy 7000 voix off 2010 c'est ta voix
2027 avoir quand même quinze mille
places supplémentaires à ce que nous
avons joué donc n'est pas vrai que là
n'est pas vrai que la réponse pénale
soit laxiste ce n'est pas vrai les
chiffres le démontrent les gens ne
perçoivent pas ça perçoivent autrement
bon alors qu'est ce que l'on fait avec
cette réalité se trouve en effet que
beaucoup de personnes qui sont
condamnées en première instance à des
peines faible on les laisse en effet en
liberté ne serait ce que parce que on
leur laisse la possibilité de doigt un
recours devant la cour d'appel libera et
donc on ne va pas mettre effectivement
toutes ces personnes qui sont en
instance n'a pas les mêmes en détention
ça deviendrait purement et simplement
une explosion même s'il ne faut pas
toujours m le critère budgétaire à la
base de la réponse pénale parce que
sinon on arriverait à cette chose
étrange en dessous deux ans on n'allait
pas en prison un moment donné c'était
réduit un an avec d'ailleurs situation
incompréhensible nous mêmes avocats
n'arrivions même pas expliqué sano
anneaux à nos clients bon alors c'est la
prise en charge de l'ensemble de ces
personnes pendant cette période
intermédiaire qui peut poser un problème
est ce que tous reconnaître des délits
je demande à voir tous réitère sa me
semble pas évident mais il est exact que
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux mêmes
beaucoup ces mêmes personnes qui peuvent
avoir des problèmes de logement de
domicile les joindre les toucher n'est
pas si facile toujours est il qu'il ya
aujourd'hui soixante dix mille personnes
qui sont pris en charge par les services
judiciaires d'insertion c'est
considérable donc ne disons pas que ça
ne fonctionne pas alors il faut
peut-être beaucoup plus et puis je sais
pas vous faire de choses je veux pas
citer victor hugo mais on sait très bien
effectivement que la question
sécuritaire est en partie liée en partie
lié à la question sociale chacun doit
être considéré comme étant en partie
responsables des choix d'une fête sinon
on est dans une société impossible mais
il faut que la société se disent il ya
effectivement une réponse sociale qui
doit être au moins identique à la
réponse ionale et à mon avis supérieur
voilà donc c'est pas vrai que l'on
puisse parler effectivement de deux
laxismes m6 s'est ressenti c'est
d'ailleurs la grande question politique
de société évidemment cécile mamelin
peut-être sur le point particulier des
agressions subies par les policiers est
ce que disais à l'instant stanislas
godon pas à ces deux là aussi de réponse
pénale pas celle ci de sévérité dans le
quantum de peine qu'est-ce que vous
répondra lorsque ce que j'entends de ce
que vient de dire monsieur godon c'est
qu'effectivement pour lui et considère
qu'il n'y a pas de réponse pénale si la
personne ne va pas en prison mais le
problème ne se résume pas à ça j'ai
envie de vous dire il ya le taux de
réponse pénale il est 90% et non pas de
83 en france il est quand même très
importants et un taux de pena d'un taux
de réponse pénale important je ne peux
pas entendre non plus qu'on ne
sanctionne pas en france les violences
faites contre les policiers nous avons
tous les jours en comparution immédiate
des procédures justement qui met en
cause des agresseurs de policiers et la
justice travaille avec la police quel
intérêt aurais les magistrats à ne pas
condamner des agresseurs de policiers ex
expliqué le moins que monsieur godon
m'expliquer pourquoi en france on en est
arrivé à dire que le blême de la police
c'était la justice est ce que vous avez
entendu un jour dire le problème de la
justice et la police jamais pourtant la
police tout comme la justice n'est pas
parfaite il y à des procédures qui sont
mal ficelés parce qu'effectivement et là
je rejoins monsieur vous donc on est sur
la même ligne de crête c'est à dire que
tous les deux nous n'avons pas beaucoup
de moyens pour y travailler un peu comme
le monde de l'hôpital j'ai envie de vous
dire que tous les services publics sont
un peu logés à la même enseigne donc on
ne peut pas laisser entendre ça le
procès en laxisme m milliards là tout à
fait bien expliqué on ne peut pas
accuser la magistrature française d'être
laxiste tous les chiffres montrent le
contraire nous les peines sont de plus
en plus sévères depuis une dizaine
d'années nous avons été condamnés par la
cdh pour des conditions de détention
d'ailleurs j'ai envie de vous dire aussi
adressez vous au législateur et
peut-être qu'après monsieur richard hu à
l'occasion de s'expliquer mais c'est le
législateur qui met en avant et c'est
son droit et nous l'appliquons parce que
nous notre mission c'est d'appliquer la
loi
son envie première c'est
qu'effectivement les gens n'aillent pas
en prison parce que ça n'est pas la
meilleure façon de lutter contre la
récidive et ça aussi c'est prouvé par
les chiffres le taux de récidive est
resté faible donc ça veut dire que
l'internât tival altération à
l'incarcération pour peu qu'on y mettre
les moyens
ça marche dans la majorité des cas donc
arrêtons de dire que la réponse pénale
c'est la prison la prison n'est pas
constructrice d'un avenir pour la
plupart des délinquants malheureusement
et c'est un magistrat qui vous le dis
j'ai le travail d'intérêt général qui
marchait pas je dis savons qu'un et
richard de la propre ça mange pas des
travaux d'intérêt général ça ne marche
pas à la légère je vous donne la parole
dans un sens je devrais quand même en
temps si cela vous avez un avocat une
magistrate qui vous disent y'a pas de il
n'y a pas de laxisme de dans la réponse
judiciaire en france
eh bien écoutez j'ai envie de vous dire
regardez ce tableau qui a été fait et à
d'ex et notamment par le sénat sur la
loi sécurité globale trois ans d'études
sur les agressions à l'encontre dès
personnes mission de service public les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique une autorité publique pardon et
des sapeurs-pompiers et vous verrez que
effectivement effectivement madame a
raison on n'en voit pas en prison lorsqu
on agresse un policier ou un pompier
c'est exactement le constat que l'on
fait et ce constat il est dramatique
parce que du coup il renvoie un message
un message évidemment de laxisme et
d'impunité à l'encontre des individus
qui attaquent des policiers et puis
aussi un message d'être un peu seul au
mieux au milieu du guet et de ne pas
être soutenus vous savez je me demande
que ça à ce que l'on applique le la
politique pénale le code pénal en france
je suis désolé vous le dire madame mais
quand ces trois ans encourus et qu' on
est en quantum moyen de 6 mois pardon
mais il ya un décalage et je ne dis pas
que tout le monde doit aller en prison
il faut pas faire de caricatures les
peines alternatives ont leur utilité
mais quand on parle et quand on a ce
débat de la politique pénale et de la
sanction il faut la corrélé avec la
gravité des infractions qui sont
commises et je suis désolé mais agressé
un policier un pompier un enseignant ce
sont des faits extrêmement graves et
quand on voit par exemple que
dernièrement un collègue sur une
manifestation à brest at attaque et
brûlé par un cocktail molotov l'individu
a été reconnue filmé par une caméra de
vidéo protection
eh bien il a eu un stage de citoyenneté
si vous appelez ça de la fermeté pardon
mais ce n'est pas de la fermeté pour
nous et des exemples comme ça on en a
tous les jours c'est bien pour ça que
nous avons demandé à ce qu'il y ait
encore une fois cette création de
l'observatoire de la réponse pénale ou
là on utilisera effectivement les
siffler remontée et on pourra comparer
les infractions commises la peine
encourue est la peine prononcée exécuté
vous avez le temps d'exposer vos
arguments alain richard on disait
attention à l'empilement des lois mais
est ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut
changer la loi pour qu'il ait une
réponse pénale contre effectivement pour
les agressions des personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique sans
doute encore du loup a changé mais je ne
préconiserai pas sur ce point là on en
revanche
pardon mais
permettez un élu de banlieue quand même
de ne pas tout à fait croire ce que vous
voulez dire l'un et l'autre nous à nous
sommes enfin
vendredi nous avions encore la réunion
des maires du département nous avons des
cas tous les jours deux situations dans
lesquelles il y à une délinquance locale
organisée
prédominante qui pèse sur la vie de la
collectivité dont beaucoup de nos villes
ou d'où d'ailleurs de nos villages
puisque ça ça s'étend un peu et là la
perspective de risque pénal pour ces
personnes pour ces et minute quand même
très faible
il est vrai que là du coup nous avons un
travail législatif affaires qu'il faut
bien préparer le code de procédure
pénale est un extraordinaire parcours
d'obstacles pour arriver à démontrer et
asseoir la culpabilité de quelqu'un et
il ya évidemment le talentueux
auxiliaires de la justice
pour qui c'est un chant de d'innovation
et de créativité à peu près infini qui
aboutit que même à beaucoup d'échecs et
ça on discutera dans mon département
aussi bien avec le responsable police
départementale que de la gendarmerie
j'entendais des sons différence de mire
que les gendarmes il ya moins ce que ce
rejet des des fonctions judiciaires mais
chez les policiers c'est les gens qui
traitent le milieu urbain
et à ya 15 20 30 ans la police
judiciaire c'était le satellite c'était
la carrière qui motiver les gens
pourquoi est ce que ce n'est plus le cas
maintenant et que vous avez 20 25%
pendant que les départements de l'île de
france mais au moins 25% du poste depuis
juillet ne sont pas occupés parce que
les teams sont découragés et donc un
chantier va s'ouvrir je pense qu'il ya
un sérieux ménage à faire au code de
procédure pénale
nous avons me semble-t-il des moyens
moins massif et moins tortueux de
garantir les droits élémentaires de la
défense je crois vraiment qu'il ya une
difficulté
la justice elle est pauvre on l'a dit la
justice eric lente la justice et surtout
méconnu les français et j'ai une partie
donc du coup elle est illisible et une
partie du procès en laxisme c'est aussi
parce que les gens ne savent pas ce que
c'est que le principe dit visuel
d'individualisation des peines ne savent
pas faire la différence entre le siège
et le parquet il ya une inculture
judiciaire en france sas et crasse et
qui n'est pas enseignée suffisamment
instruction c ur du coup chacun regarde
évidemment à l'aune de son problème et
en plus on est quand même dans une
société où le statut de victime
heureusement quand même airs de plus en
plus reconnue mais du coup c'est moi
victime quelle est la réponse apportée à
mon agresseur aux délinquants et du coup
ça paraît toujours évidemment rien à ce
que le délinquant ça sera la première
fois qu'il commettra s'attaque t oui on
a prononcera pas de la prison mais y
aura un suivi socio judiciaire ou une
tentative de réinsertion qui pourra être
bancal et on le sait aussi ce tout ne
fonctionne pas parfaitement mais de deux
du point de vue de la victime ce n'est
jamais assez et tant qu'on a de cette
inculture judiciaire tant qu'on n'aura
pas fait ce travail là avant de faire
des lois et je pense qu aura toujours ce
problème dans l'opinion sur au delà de
la lenteur de la pauvreté des moyens et
de lisibilité john rossi rejoint
monsieur godon sur un autre point je
crois qu'on peut pas être satisfaits de
l'état des statistiques judiciaires aux
jo honnêtement ça je suis d'accord
qu'elles sont aussi difficilement
lisible
ici assure-t-il cherche du bon objet
honnêtement nous n'avons pas de
statistiques valables c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu d'ailleurs cette opération
de l'observatoire pour apprécier pour
essayer de quantifier le degré de
gravité de la réponse justice par
rapport à un indice de gravité des
infractions
non seulement nous savons pas faire ça
mais je suis pas sûr que nous le
cherchons et donc je crois que si
quelque chose d'utile doit sortir des
états généraux ce serait où que notre
système judiciaire parce qu'elle pénal
mais le simili apprécie beaucoup de
choses à dire
aujourd'hui on est un tableau de bord de
ce que nous faisons vraiment je crois
vraiment honnêtement que ce que produit
la statistique judiciaire aujourd'hui ne
justifie pas ce terme fait effectivement
comment comment améliorer un système si
on n'en connaît pas les statistiques
c'est vrai que c'est difficile d'avoir
des statistiques très fiable et je me
souviens d'avoir lu un article sur
l'observatoire des chiffres de la
délinquance est lui même des échos coût
de 10 ans c'était très compliqué mais
aussi parce qu'il est compliqué dans une
société montmagny nick qui est un petit
peu tous ces blancs c'est noir il n'y a
pas de zone grise etc c'est donc très
compliqué et j'ai envie de vous dire que
la justice c'est un travail
d'équilibriste entre d'un côté on a
quand même on est quand même dans un
état de droit 1 j'ai envie de dire qu'on
est quand même un petit peu dans un état
de droit en france encore on a donc d'un
côté les droits de la défense on allait
droit bien sûr de la victime monsieur
l'a dit il est très très normal que les
victimes sont davantage reconnu est
prise en considération je pense qu'on
peut voir d'ailleurs au travers du
procès actuel sur les attentats du 13
novembre que la parole des victimes est
quand même humainement entendu je trouve
que on a quand même fait de d'énormes
efforts là dessus et là la justice s'est
adapté c'est quand même un procès
exceptionnel mais c'est un travail
d'équilibriste et on ne peut pas venir
dire aujourd'hui je suis désolé monsieur
le sénateur mais quand on est
législateur qu'il faut alléger au
maximum la procédure pénale alors qu'on
est en train de nous donner un texte qui
complexifie la procédure pénale encore
plus on va pas en discuter je pense
qu'on aura plus trop le temps mais en
réalité la procédure pénale elle est
complexifiée parking pas par le
magistrat pas par le police il pas par
l'avocat elle et complexifie par le
législateur lui même parce qu'il ya des
stands nombre parce que aussi parce qu'à
des standards aux standards
internationaux le droit au silence avec
ses doigts
donc je pense qu'on ne peut pas quand on
est les six sata on ne peut pas venir
dire c'est tout simple c'est un coup de
baguette magique on va aller fier
alléger la procédure et je suis d'accord
avec vous berné la police judiciaire
c'est un gros souci parce que
effectivement nous avons beaucoup de mal
à avoir des personnes qui veulent faire
ce travail qui pourtant un travail
fondamental pour l'état de droit et pour
faire des bonnes procédures qui ne tombe
pas après devant le tribunal parce que
c'est des procédures tant il faut se
poser la question on ne peut pas
condamner des gens simplement parce
qu'on a reconnu il faut des preuves on
est dans un état de droit et il faut des
preuves merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat en passe